hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be going
over the bioesculin test or the
bioesculin agar test
sometimes this auger is abbreviated bea
before we jump into it i want to make
sure you know two things first i have a
playlist on microbiology diagnostic
tests
that covers
all of the selective and differential
augers all of those tests like the
catalase test and the lecithinase test
and the coagulase test
and all of the different stains that you
need to be familiar with you're taking a
microbiology lab so if you're taking a
microbiology course definitely check out
that playlist it has like everything you
need
also
if you want to grab a picture of the
final board with all of the answers
filled in just grab it from the link in
the description below and that is your
free study notes
so now let's talk about bioesculent
auger it is selective and differential
what do these things mean selective
means that it allows some things to grow
while inhibiting others and then of the
things that it allows to grow the
differential aspect is that there are
ways to
to observe
basically metabolic differences to be
able to distinguish like one species
from another
so in the case of bile esculent agar it
is used to isolate and differentiate
enterococcus species
so specifically in pterococcus from
streptococcus species and other sorts of
gram-positive
cocci
so
how does it work well first it's got a
few different components we're going to
go over it has bile salts sometimes
you'll see these referred to as oxal or
ox bile
and those are just different words for
the same thing but basically different
bile salts these inhibit the growth of
most
gram-positive
bacteria
so if you have like a mixed culture
or you have
a culture of gram-positive bacteria
gram-positive spheres and you're not
sure what they are if you put them on
bio-escalant auger most of them are
going to be inhibited mainly except in
terracocci and maybe a few strep species
now this agar also contains peptic
digests of animal tissue
uh and or beef extract now these make it
what's known as a complex medium right
it's not chemically defined where every
single batch of bio-escalant agar is
exactly the same
um instead you know different lots of
animal tissue different lots of beef
extracts can have slightly different
you know macromolecule concentrations
and slightly different nutrient
concentrations and so it's what we call
a complex media
but the reason that the animal tissue or
beef extracts are included is because
they provide carbon
nitrogen
and other essential factors think things
like vitamins right
there's also auger
of course the auger is to make it a
solid media
and then it has two other kind of key
ingredients one is esculene
and the other
is called ferric
citrate
now it is the esculene and the ferric
citrate together that cause a color
change
that gives what we call a positive
reaction or a positive result in the
bioesculin test or the biolascular auger
test
this test is also usually done in slant
tubes
if you've not seen these before
basically it's where the molten media
you know the auger has been added
but it's still very very hot and so it's
a liquid molten consistency and it's
poured in tubes and then the tubes are
placed at an angle usually about a 45
degree angle while they cool and the
media solidifies and then the auger
that's inside even though it's a solid
auger
a solid auger medium it's at a slant so
that's most common for this type of test
now how does this test work
so remember we're looking at
enterococcus the pleural enterococci
formula formerly these were called group
d scrap so you might still see that in
some older resources
these produce
an enzyme called
esculenase
remember whenever a word ends in ace
that means it's an enzyme so esculenas
carries out this reaction
esculene
plus bile
with escalinase this enzyme escylnase
will hydrolyze
esculene
into a different compound escalatin
resculatin i hear it pronounced both
ways escalatin
plus glucose
okay and then this product esculeton
right here
reacts with ferric citrate and that was
the other important ingredient here so
the esculene gets hydrolyzed by that
esculanase enzyme and then the product
of that the escalatin reacts with the
ferric citrate this forms a phenol
precipitate that is a dark brown
or black
color
now
you might need to know this many
bacteria can hydrolyze esculene
but only a very few mainly the
enterococci can do so in the presence of
the bile salts so that's another way in
which the bile salts are
selective here
so here's the steps for how you would do
a bile escalant auger test you would
take a colony typically this is from a
blood agar plate i am preparing another
video that should come out in a few
weeks hopefully
on blood auger plates how they're made
and on the different hemolysis
patterns the different hemolytic
patterns that we see
in different types of bacteria
and so when we're looking at
these the enterococci remember they're
very closely related to strep to
streptococcus that's why they used to be
classified as streptococci
but these are typically going to be
growing on blood agar plates so you take
a colony
excuse me
take a colony from a blood agar plate
aseptically right that means without
introducing any kind of contamination
and then you streak it on the slant so
basically you're taking a sterile loop
picking up a colony and you want to see
if that colony is in terracoxide or
something else
and then you
streak it
you know
down the surface of the slant so it's a
streak down the surface of the auger
you're not puncturing the auger like you
do for some other tests
then um i'll go ahead and put a streak
here too to be for a different colony
and then this is important you leave the
caps loose
this allows oxygen to
be present in here to diffuse in so it
allows these bacteria ample oxygen for
aerobic respiration purposes
so that's why you have to leave the
capsules you incubate for 35 to 37
degrees celsius for 24 to 48 hours and
then you interpret based on the color
change
basically if there's no color change
none of this dark brown or black that's
considered a negative result an example
of a negative result would come from
streptococcus pyogenes
a positive result or a positive reaction
like you would get with enterococcus
spicalis
is where you see this dark brown or
black coloration forming and again
that's that precipitate
because the enterococci have the enzyme
that carries out this reaction and gets
this product to
react with ferric citrate and create
that color change
now
you see here i've kind of drawn this two
ways the the brown or black color it
could fill the entire auger especially
if you're using a smaller tube for your
slant or it might only
fill like the upper portion it just kind
of depends on how much activity there is
how many
enterococci cells there are
and the time that it takes for the
the precipitates to kind of diffuse
through the medium basically
remember this playlist right here
microbiology diagnostic tests you can
learn about
you know a dozen more different kinds of
augers that you may be studying in class
plus a lot of other diagnostic tests
catalase tests coagulase test lesson
finish test things like that so check
that out good luck studying grab your
free study notes at the link below that
will include a picture of the final
board
and i will see you next time thanks for
watching biology professor bye